hmm let's go Knight f6 all right yuzo
Indian I've been doing this a lot um
what's the scoop with that move um
interesting so I mean I'm definitely not
booked up opening theory yeah needs a
lot of work on chest cube there come as
the Neo Indian Sarah one attack I was
not familiar with that ecl code is e 0 0
apparently I don't know how accurate
those are by the way I like throwing a
question this Bishop let's see what
wants to do it you can take my nightie
going to run away you're going to
maintain the pin and be a pain if the
bishop goes here then I could be assured
that it's not going to come off in this
direction to defend dark squares so
that's what I'm what to do right now I'm
assuming my opponent is booked up with
this type of a move I don't know if
that's a good assumption to make but um
take and then throw a check in with my
bishop or give a check right now let try
that
I was just recalling a searching for
Bobby Fischer the whole lot don't bring
the Queen out so early that scene right
there don't bring the Queen out early
and the other one is saying to bring the
Queen on early who said what who was
who's saying what in that anyhow this is
a this is 8 not so typical to bring be
bringing the Queen up this early but my
idea is to get out of the pin and then
try and pile up on this night so what
about takes here first no no no no let's
pile up on them I don't even want to
give white the opportunity to take my
night
alrighty so now I chop the night and
work on these ponds being doubled and i
believe by force that's what we're going
to see no matter what I get to decide so
i could take here and so let's do it
there is no pond recapture this pond is
pinned so after a night move here I'm
threatening Knight takes Knight I'm
assuming the follow-up is going to being
just III oh this is the only move I'm
pretty sure Knight takes pawn have to
regain that material what's up what's
the story here what else could white
maybe be thinking of besides Knight
takes pawn are they trying to pick up
the pondcrete capture okay night here
it's not they know it's a threat but
it's easily met with e3 is there a
better thing that I could be doing
instead of knight c6 I don't know
let's go knight c6 okay there we go and
now maybe I should be a pest Bishop here
is met with night be three so that's not
so great what about be five that seems a
bit off to do that how do i finish my
development I am a bit concerned about
rook be one to be five my queen is kind
of stuck hmm what do I do
d5 bishop d6 hmm I'm not sure what to do
here I have there's some structural
damage here but so what how do i take
advantage of that I'm stuck Bishop here
there's night takes at the very least
file by Bishop takes bishop hmm I just
don't know is that okay to just not know
try it it's a little bit scary seeing
this Bishop cutting off my king like
this I do think though that my deep on
needs to contribute and I just was not
seeing a way to bring out my bishop in
this direction so i kind of am forced
into going in this direction i need to
get this deep on involved and then think
about planning my bishop here i do have
to be concerned about night moves to be
five in one of these two squares
especially if the bishop decides to come
back to g3 soon ok now that I was not
expecting and I it's an easy recapture
and easy move to respond to its just
recapture I'm building my Center and now
I'm able to see the position much more
clearly much more clearly so let's start
off with this threatening to win upon
but I'd be I have to have to be cautious
about that i don't know that i really
want to do that i might want it I
probably want to just play Bishop to c5
rook to be eight it might be tough for
my rooks to pivot on the B file if the
bishop decides to play 2 g-3 yeah i am
not going to take that pawn I don't care
about him I want to be in a spot to
eventually meet a c4 move with D for you
know what I'm talking about I'm talking
about well let's get castled first
there's a bishop check but it's harmless
I'm talking about if take stakes well no
actually that wouldn't be in place would
it okay well now i think i do want to
take here mmm no not so fast let me do
this first and now I'm ready to really
just take on this square with my bishop
and then even though the double ponds
one of them is just one of them as well
one of them is just an extra and I could
pivot on this square ok so now I'm going
to deal with the bishop first this rook
could be making use of this square now I
really just want to get to this square
next rip to d3 or even to d5 and if my
rook has ever captured my pawns are
repaired and it turns out to be a really
nice structure which works well with my
remaining Bishop 50 seconds each
okay um I want to sing that my scene got
the lightscribe bishops are going to be
off the board i want my queen in the
spot to watch over the light squares and
I could do this with the okay now pawn
takes here this is my weakest pun so I
want to get rid of them immediately e
takes is needed I play c5 and I'm
threatening pawn takes I want to target
the sepan next this is the only
recapture there's a lot of time being
wasted here Oh what's the scoop here I
have this covered time issue okay this
is leading to mate already
okay good game let me back up let me
back up and let's see about where
there's improvements because this is
interesting line ok so again if you're
interested in learning more about it
it's the the name of it at least is the
Neo Indian sarin attack so I think this
turns out to be okay it's doubled pawns
it looks really messy but it's very
uncomfortable for me to finish my queen
side development you know this is an
interesting imbalance because I mean how
can we how can we summarize this
position best I don't know if what I'm
about to say is the best way to
summarize it but at least these are my
thoughts and it's that white has a
compromise queenside structure versus
black having difficulty developing their
Queen Bishop doesn't seem like there's a
smooth way to bring that guy out all
right so that's like the little
trade-off it's much smoother for why
it's just III which was played it's
getting the bishop out now this right
here I think there's an improvement
what's so what might be better is just
bring the bishop out to let's say e2 I
think that that's going to be better
because like I was saying this is this
is my troubled piece and as soon as you
take my night well it's no longer
troubled this is a wonderful home right
here and my center is built so this is
this is where the tables turn this is it
turns right when the structure changes
so night takes you're reinforcing my
Center and I have
home i'm able to solve that issue right
away so what might be better is just
Bishop to let's say e to if I ever
capture you just recapture you might
have to be a little bit concerned
somehow with both bishops being
unprotected not seeing anything jump out
at me right away but just have that in
mind pieces being unprotected lead to
tactics after this capture both your
bishops would be unprotected I don't see
a way to exploit that though so Bishop
e2 i think is going to be better and I
think what I'll be needing to go forward
with at some point is like a capture and
then following up with a pawn push but
it's definitely going to be a much more
difficult game a much more difficult
struggle then after the Knight takes
Knight right here and the the structure
has been clarified it's a much much
easier to play for me and I think black
is standing better now because of that
structural change so look into the
Bishop e2 move keep this night as is
he's good when you do a piece comparison
my your night versus my night yours is
better both of us do well to not capture
one another's night that's another way
you could view it I take your night I'm
repairing your pawns in some way he
takes as the response as the only
response